it was basically over 50 years ago I got
off the bus said forbes and morewood and
started my education here as a freshman
piano major and at that time it was a
music department at carnegie institute
of technology and today it's a school of
music at carnegie mellon university so
that kind of summarizes the growth i
think people are intrigued by its
longevity and it's how it's come up from
where did from it's sort of technical
basis and I think that it's part of what
tells the story of Pittsburgh's oh well
which is the combination of the
industrial past and the excitement of
the cultural present from day one it was
exciting and wonderful i would go to
symphony concerts twice each weekend be
so enthused so inspired I'd come right
back to this building and start
practicing for two hours it was just
this incredibly diverse place really
everybody was so incredibly focused on
what it was that they were doing were
also part of this world class
international university and as such our
music students who come here can get the
best training possible for careers but
they can also experiment develop that
other side of their skill set I've been
able to take classes in the English
department and in other areas and
complete that major and I think it just
made me a more rounded person and a
better artists if we were just a music
conservatory we wouldn't have this other
people around
inspire us and do different things and
new things the concepts that I've
attended have been electrifying
difficult difficult pieces are really
really well presented and showing that
the school is very good at not only
teaching the basics but also willing to
go out on the loom there are a lot of
really great moments one was definitely
the New York trip that the Philharmonic
took a few years ago when Keith Lockhart
came and do his guest conducting with
Mahler one and being able to play in
that hall was really inspiring and it's
a really great hall what inspires me
most is the quality of the faculty here
and I think it's really the faculty that
brings in the great students and they're
the ones who meet with Us Weekly and
really monitor our development and mold
the people that were going to become and
they're all performers too so during the
week they teach you in lessons and in
classes and just by talking with them
you hear all the stories of how they've
made it and all the places they've been
and then on the weekends you know we go
downtown and we see them do what they
talk about the teachers pushed me and
got me to the level that I needed to to
be at in order to perform successfully
in the real world what matters is what
happens after you leave the school where
you go what you do a kind of
contribution you make their society to
the music work our graduates go all over
the world and anytime I've been anywhere
I've found our students participating in
music in those countries where they are
in the world performing today speaks
volumes I think about Carnegie Mellon's
reputation for being a world-class music
school and having its students
outperforming working professionally
consistently the Carnegie Mellon name
means a lot whether it's music or any
other field well it means that they have
met every single challenge that Carnegie
Mellon has thrown at them we're not for
the background we received here the
education we received here we
not be these little happy success
stories along the way literally every
aspect of my career has been nurtured
supported and fostered by this place
there isn't a day that I don't feel
lucky that I made that decision to get
on that bus had such great history and
to be a part of it is something that I
take great pride in even though we're
always trying new things it's classical
music as the field that's very rooted in
tradition and it's interesting to note
that we're the ones kind of keeping the
ball rolling for 100 years we're still
here